my understanding of parent alienation is
that one parent intentionally keeps the
children away from the other parent it
can male or female and there I guess
there are different incentives whether
whether it's money or resentment you
know because we all have resentment so
you broke up with me so you're not gonna
see your son today
you know or you're not gonna see your
daughter and you know it does exist
because I don't know if it's a syndrome
or if it's you know what it's labeled as
but I know from the interviews that
we've had there's an emotional drain
there's health disorders there's
psychological problems that happen when
you can't see your child or you're not
this attitude of you have to pay before
you play with your kids and you can't
pay so you go through this withdrawal of
I got to go back to work I got to do
something and eventually these parents
hit a wall and they commit suicide or
they become more addicted to substance
abuses and more alcoholism you know and
there is a parent alienation out there
some people say it's not a syndrome I
didn't get involved in that aspect of it
and I just grabbed the information that
I thought was necessary to bring it to
life and I hope I got that you know that
people can learn from it well did you
speak to a woman I think who had written
a book it was I think we got that from
an archive okay because we thought it
was interesting that that was a
statement she made in the film but the
one that wrote a book that I really
admired and she ended up passing away
was dr. Jane Major and I attended one of
her classes breakthrough parenting and
you know she was teaching parents that
you know it wasn't their fault what was
happening and they could still be
parents you know send the crisp
send the birthday card do whatever you
can and in hopes that the relationship
is still there and you know she ended up
passing away I think before the film was
shown but I kept her in there her words
are powerful she brought out the
perineal a nation syndrome and of it
and and it was good because here's a
woman that was talking about it you know
it wasn't that just women are doing it
that obviously men you know can alienate
their children as well from mothers you
know moms cry every day you know the
husband is not helping out and I think
that's what it's really about it's like
people just step back see what's best
for your child and if the parents unfit
the drug addict like they said in the
movie there's some statements there yes
I can understand I don't think if
they're healthy and have things to offer
the kid as they're growing up they
should be set aside did they talk about
what some of the signs were of this
parental alienation syndrome as I found
it very interesting I think a lot of
depression I've I have you know dealing
with some of the interviews you can seal
you can see that you know they're just
in this zone of they can't believe just
what happened to them and you know I'm
not a doctor I don't know the exact you
know you know sure sometimes and things
like that I just I know touching on the
emotional part and feeling the pain of
somebody that's going through something
like that was an experience for me it
was like I could feel that I could feel
what they're going through through the
tears or through whatever it was like
man that if that's parenting alienation
syndrome then this person must have it
because you don't fake something like
that
yeah many of your interviews showed just
the emotion behind it you know even even
if it was just a twinge at the end of
somebody's sort of cracking a little bit
but you could definitely see that and
were there some that you just felt were
were too much to show and you cut them
out that was a hard process we you know
I did the best I can not to cut them out
because if that's what was happening to
them here in tears and everything if
that person went home and was in so much
pain and alone they were contemplating
something far worse than themselves
killing themselves you know and so I
just did the best I can that maybe we
can find some treatment and some hope
here for people that are going through
it
you